hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com
so very quickly i'm a professional
trainer and i'm here to discuss with you
everything that i see at work all the
different tools and techniques that i
use
to make money on the markets so if you
want to know about all the stuff
you guys are in the right place today i
want to make another update on gamestop
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so i'm very happy about the
new counting i'm having so i'm gonna
show you very quickly this
again and then we're gonna do some
longer term now that i have this new
accounting
i'm gonna update you with my new view
that is actually very close to the first
one
it's the only thing that has changed is
this corrective pattern
that was actually it's not finished yet
so
you know it's a bit early to say i found
it
but i'm giving this to you guys before
it actually happened
and i'm very confident it's gonna happen
soon so in this video i'm gonna give you
some levels i'm gonna give you some
dates
and we're gonna see if yes or not
this new counting is correct
and once again the one i had before i've
always told you that there was something
that is not you know fitting
i was missing the volumes in here for
now
it all makes sense actually that volumes
go down so let me just quickly remind
you
what is my new counting in india to a
theory we have what we call
double and triple threes which is a
combination
of corrective patterns that can be
zigzag flat or triangles
and it is moving sideways here
i have a sideways correction all this
mess
is actually going sideways so this is
the definition of what we can call a
complex correction
that is a combination of a simpler
correction
zigzag flat and triangles here i have my
abc and here i have my triangle let me
get rid in this analysis of the smalls
abcs that i
have inside my triangle all right so you
can see better
let me put this one slightly bigger all
right and this is my triangle as you can
see
so i have here my zigzag here my
triangle and
this is only the second wave of a larger
degree wave counting so let me show you
guys
here i'm going to go to daily there are
many things i want to
tell you guys so let's just do them one
by one
so now this is a one
all right this is a two and we're gonna
have the three
actually guys maybe the three is only
going to 800 okay maybe it's more like
this
it's like this all right one two
three four and five
so maybe we're gonna have something like
this but something here is not fitting
guys i'm doing this right now
and i can see you know you need to have
for your idiot wave counting to be
you know correct and precise and
trustful you need to have something that
is visually
looking good and this is not looking
good guys you can see that my one two is
way too bigger compared to my three four
five
so maybe the third wave is going to go
to 800
guys this is very bullish what i'm
saying i'm giving you right now
i don't know maybe we're having
something like this
it would actually make more sense but
whatever i'm not sure what is going to
happen with the three
four and five where would be this level
i don't know if the three is going to
100 like the five is going to 800
but definitely one of them would go to
800 i'm very convinced of that
but here what i wanted to tell you yeah
is that
so if we need to analyze what is
happening right now so we have a double
three
but we can have a triple three so why
not all right
and the answer for me is actually here
you can see when i connect
the high that is here with the height
that is here
this is giving me a trend line that once
is broken on the upside is probably
going to generate
some bullish momentum so it's probably
gonna be the third wave
so i don't know how we can actually do
one more
correction here without breaking it so
maybe we would break it
maybe you know the kind of bearish case
for me
would be that we break it and then we do
some kind of a flat correction all right
this is possible as well that we break
it we somehow we test it
and maybe we do a flat correction like
this so this would be still a sideways
move
but then this correction would be very
very long which is possible but you know
it doesn't look to me like this is where
we are going another thing i wanted to
show you so let's forget for now about
this bearish scenario so you can see
even my bearish scenario guys is quite
you know bullish because i have a lot of
bullish signals in this
stock here guys something very
interesting you know is actually telling
me that
something is up is that look at the
cycles of the macd
all right so positive cycle here
then negative cycle between the force of
feb
and the 25th of feb then a positive
cycle of 2 or 3 weeks
negative cycle of 2 or 3 weeks then we
started the positive cycle and
right away we got in the negative
territory
so how can we analyze this information
the only thing that we can actually say
is that
we are in something that is messy that
is not
organized when you see this kind of
stuff happening
so when you are in a messy situation
this is only giving you one information
but that is very precious
is that probably this is just a complex
correction
when you're having this kind of you know
not clean signals when something is not
making sense for example volume is not
coming
macd turning negative when we are
supposed to be in a bullish development
this kind of information is just telling
you that we
probably are in a complex correction
this is the indicator you need
to follow and keep in mind so this is
the reason why
i'm very convinced that my
new accounting that is here so i repeat
is just a zigzag
and a triangle a combination of a zigzag
and a triangle
is actually what is happening and if
this
is a correction you need to you know
always ask yourself what are we
correcting
here we are correcting this first wave
so this is a second wave
corrective and after the correction what
is going to happen
we're going to have a bullish wave it's
you know it's just always like this
so if this move was clean then i know we
are bearish
you know if the bearish moves are clean
and giving me perfect signals
then i know that the trend is bearish
and probably bullish moves are going to
be corrective and messy
here my first wave is very clean let me
show you guys this again
my first wave here let's go into four
hours so we see to be better
is a beautiful one two three four five
you see
one two three four five
you know this is the perfect counting
this is i could find this in the book i
could find it here
i always have the book you guys on the
side and like i showed you i checked
you know i'm here i read this so many
times and i still find some precious
information
this is available online guys all right
you just type as i said
idiot with principle thrust and pressure
pdf second link on google
if you're interested just have a look at
this but it's not easy to read if you
are more interested about something
easier click on the link in my
description
of this video and you're gonna receive a
free video where i sum up everything
here and i show you how to use it
so here this is telling me that bullish
moves are clean
so we are bullish and bearish moves that
are corrective
here moving sideways but anyways this is
corrective
are messy and giving me signals that are
not clean
and a lot of things that don't add up
actually
so one more thing i want to show you
guys very interesting all right
i'm an option trader guys as you know
and let's see what is the synthetic
short first thing so i tap
160 i get all this information from
yahoo finance right now
five percent of synthetic short so let's
check what is the dtc today
the synthetic short is five percent all
right
it's here as you can see i compute it
and then i add it here
the natural short interest as of the
15th of april so there is a bit of delay
but you know yes that these reports are
published
every fortnight so we're having 25
percent of total
short interest all right so if i compute
the dtc day to cover
for the monthly volume that i found here
we have 1.3
but what is growing and what is
interesting to notice
is that the volume is so low guys the
weekly volume is at 3.8 million shares
so it gives us a weekly dtc of 3.6
so we are approaching the critical
levels of
around 5 to 10 where actually hedge
funds
start to cut their short positions and
their short positions
for now let's see what is going to
happen for the next
report but for now they're not
increasing it the only thing that is
increasing is the synthetic short wizard
moves up
and one last thing i want to show you
guys that i keep an eye on
is the volatility and the delta of the
800 strike for the july maturity
so once again the volatility is here 193
which i monitor guys i told you last
time it went down to 189
you can check my other video and if this
level drops too much
the associated delta where the formula
is
here guys it's just black scholes
formula it's very easy
to actually compute yourself the meaning
of the delta is the probability for an
option to finish in the money so it
means gamestop
as i'm checking here the july 800 strike
800 here and july here guys
so this is october so the probability to
finish above the 800 level in october
is now 40 percent and look what would
happen if this
drops 200 for example so that's why if
this drops
you have information yes because then
the delta would be
five percent so the probability to go
above the 800 level in october would
only be
one chance over 20 right now guys as you
can see
we are having 40
chance of trading above 800 so i keep an
eye on
this one for you guys so
this is also bullish information
that i have coming from the option
market and once again you can see that
the synthetic short
is distributed like this so if gamestop
goes at crazy level like for example 800
the synthetic shot goes to 25 and this
can create the gamma squeeze
so that's why i'm so bullish that's it
for me guys i hope you enjoyed this
video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys